[Music]
on this monday night the
commander-in-chief cleared
to go home the u.s president's prognosis
he may not entirely be out of the woods
yet all the medications he's on
and his message to the world as more of
his inner circle become infected
ontario's kovid 19 testing turmoil the
confusion and the crisis
as quebec reimposes even more rules
a canadian orphan finally leaves a
syrian camp the crucial role canada's
special forces played
in securing her freedom and the highest
honors bestowed on an alberta-based
scientist
everyone in canada should be so grateful
to michael the nobel winning work
that saved millions of lives
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the latest on president
trump who has
not fully recovered from covid19 he has
just been discharged from the hospital
the president walked out of the walter
reed medical center wearing a mask he
was only diagnosed friday so it's
assumed he's still contagious
we're told he's still taking two drugs
including one that's usually given to
people who are severely ill with covid19
he gave a thumbs up and was driven to
the presidential helicopter then flown
to the south lawn of the white house
where an outbreak of covid19
continues to spread through his inner
circle
earlier today trump tweeted i will be
leaving the great walter reed medical
center today at 6
30 p.m feeling really good don't be
afraid of covid
don't let it dominate your life i feel
better than i did 20 years ago
while covid19 is not a youth serum and
the virus is dominating
his life and his administration not to
mention the families of the more than
two hundred and ten thousand americans
it has killed trump's press secretary
kaylee mcani is the latest on his staff
to test positive for covid19 she's been
briefing reporters as recently as
yesterday without a mask
at least 14 people in trump's inner
circle are now known to be positive
this afternoon as doctors agreed he was
ready to be discharged though
he's still taking at least two
medications over the past 24 hours
the president has continued to improve
he's met or exceeded all standard
hospital discharge criteria
our plan is to give the fourth dose of
rendezvous this evening before he goes
back to the white house
and we've made arrangements to deliver
the fifth and final dose of his
treatment course at the white house
tomorrow evening
he continues on dexamethasone jackson
proskow is at the walter reed medical
center where trump just left jackson
trump
isn't cured he still has kobig 19. and
yet
what did he do as soon as he walked up
the steps of the white house
good evening to you donna the
president's release was essentially
choreographed as almost a campaign ad
and as he walked up the steps of the
white house he paused on the balcony
outside the white house doors
and took off his mask remember he is
still likely infectious
and then he stepped into the white house
maskless this entire
evening though really was made for the
cameras there were lights set up here on
the steps of walter reed
his official photographer was seen with
him on the balcony of the white house
and now he's heading inside where he
tries to manage a pandemic
that has killed more than 210 thousand
americans and has sickened many people
including him
within the white house shortly before
being discharged from walter reed
medical center the president's doctors
continued to paint a rosy picture of the
world's most famous covid19 patient
though he may not entirely be out of the
woods yet his clinical status
support the president's safe return home
despite donald trump's continued use of
therapies typically reserved for severe
cases of the virus
he will be allowed to recover at home
though he's likely still infectious
and surrounded by a mountain of
unanswered questions about his health
so you have to believe given what we've
seen this past
four days five days that this is all to
project an image
it's to project an image of not being
vulnerable or to project an image that
everything's okay
it's not clear if trump's hospital
departure may have been ill-advised
experts see it as part of an epidemic of
troubling behavior by the white house
24 hours earlier the president took a
joy ride past supporters and
media outside the hospital enclosing
himself in an suv with two secret
service agents
you know the reality is is that this was
a dangerous move there is
no medical benefit for this to have
taken place
it violates cdc guidelines that come
from the president's own administration
there's now a growing cluster of cases
connected directly to the executive
mansion
including press secretary kaley mcinanny
and two of her aides
despite her own close contact with
confirmed cases
mcaney had chosen not to quarantine
before her positive diagnosis
and was still at work on sunday where
she briefed reporters without a mask
i'm not going to give you a detailed
readout with time stamps of every time
the president's tested
she and trump's doctors still refuse to
say when the president last tested
negative
a critical question that could shed
light on whether trump was infectious
during the presidential debate with joe
biden
or the campaign rallies that followed
biden says he's still open to future
debates
if the scientists say that it's safe and
the distances are safe
then i think that's fine i'll do
whatever the experts say
is appropriate thing to do back at the
white house at least
three reporters and two house staff have
come down with the virus
several report having no contact from
the white house
and no attempt at contact tracing
while the white house has a fully
functioning medical unit inside it's not
clear how they'll manage
isolating a potentially infectious
patient one thing is clear they will
likely try and keep the president inside
the residence and out of the west wing
but donna as we've seen over the past
few days the president has
little or no interest in following those
types of guidelines or common sense
donna all right jackson proskow thank
you
in ottawa today prime minister justin
trudeau was asked when he was last
tested for covet 19.
earlier in september i had a bit of a
a bit of a throat tickle it's probably
the best way i could say it a bit of a
raspy throat
so i checked with my doctor and he
recommended i get tested
i got tested it was negative
and i i went back to work a few days
later when the when the doctor told me
i was clear to do it test results aren't
coming back that quickly for everyone
there is a backlog of more than 65
000 tests in ontario it's taking up to a
week to get results and that's causing
huge problems with contact tracing which
has to happen fast
to break the chain of transmission an
average of 71 000 people in canada were
tested each day over the past seven days
1.7 percent of them tested positive
ontario and quebec account for more than
80 percent of the new infections in this
country
and this is the picture today quebec is
reporting nearly 1200 new cases the
fourth consecutive day of more than
1 000 new cases ontario has
more than 600 reported today manitoba
51 alberta is recording more than 200
new cases that's the second day in a row
a two-day tally that's not been seen
since april
and bc has 120.
and a hospital in d.c the delta hospital
is now closed to new admissions as it
deals with a covid19 outbreak
there are 35 confirmed cases and seven
people
have died we are watching
hospitalizations
again the numbers are highest in ontario
and quebec
and they're slowly rising an average of
585 people in canada
were in the hospital for covet 19 on any
given day during the last
seven day period canada's chief public
health officer fears that will begin to
rise because the virus is beginning to
appear again
inside long-term care homes especially
in canada's two biggest provinces
that's a signal that you could get more
hospitalizations
and then later on mortality or death so
that is
clearly something that you got us just
immediately
uh prevent otherwise the health care
system is the next
sort of frontier that might be
overwhelmed and we want to prevent that
as of yesterday at least 219 residents
in long-term care in quebec had covet 19
and 124
residents in ontario care homes quebec
has reimposed restrictions in covet 19
hot spots and ontario is spending more
money
to try to keep schools safe that doesn't
address the strain on
labs that do the testing and on the
contact tracers
abigail beeman reports so i have to go
online i didn't know
confusion at this ottawa test center
closed until tuesday as all centers in
the province moved to online booking
someone told you to come here from the
doctor we're working hard to make sure
that the information is as clear as
possible not clear enough for fred gload
waiting for a test as he cares for older
relatives
now everybody's saying well they're
doing their best
people are dying doing your best isn't
good enough the testing
regime is in crisis the backlog is huge
ontario wide we're over 90 000 backlot
cases
and there is no obvious way to chip away
at that before some of those
specimens expire the prime minister says
federal labs are chipping in
but the numbers don't match including
for ontario for
a thousand tests a day and additional
federal labs
will be added on contact tracing we have
agreements in place with ontario quebec
and alberta with more to come
for other provinces and territories we
could have another
700 people added to the ranks and still
be unable to contact trace
with the same reach and results as when
infection rates
were lower ontario's premier announced
35 million dollars for schools and hot
spots
quebec announced more restrictions in
the province's three red zones
closing gyms canceling team sports and
changes at schools including mandatory
masks for high school students
all the actions that we are taking
today could could and should
prevent the closing of schools and on
the global stage a canadian virologist
is one of the newest nobel laureates
and he's worried about canada's
manufacturing whole
we need the ability as a country to
respond
at the manufacturing level that's
highlight i think of it
especially has highlighted a big
deficiency
in canada's ability to respond to
epidemics
manufacturing for things like our own
vaccines and
tests monday the deputy prime minister
promised the first shipments of rapid
tests will arrive from the u.s
next week and she promised more to
announce on the rapid test front
quote very soon abigail beeman global
news
ottawa two new federal benefits are now
available to canadians people who are
forced to take time off work to care for
a dependent because of the pandemic
can apply for financial help michael
couture explains what's available
and who qualifies
[Music]
playing with her eight-month-old
daughter is a welcome break from the
daily stress
of covid19 julia wilson and her husband
were self-employed but are now
unemployed because of the pandemic and
wilson can't work
because her daughter was diagnosed with
congenital thyroid disorder
meaning she can't go to day care
anything like a simple cold or anything
she won't be able to fight as well as
others which could land her in the
hospital
it's why she had to apply for the new
caregiver benefit which started today
it will provide 500 dollars per week for
up to 26 weeks in households where one
person missed
more than half their work week because
they have to care for a family member
as a result of covid19 it's estimated
seven hundred thousand people will apply
for it also starting today
paid sick leave that will make up five
hundred dollars per week for a maximum
of two weeks for people who had
contracted covet 19
or had to isolate because they were
exposed to the virus
the government believes nearly four and
a half million canadians could benefit
from it
that's a major victory for canadian
workers both of the new benefits were
the result of negotiations with the ndp
to keep the liberal minority government
afloat
the conservatives point out there's a
gap between the first wave of benefits
and this one
blaming the liberals if some canadians
fall through the cracks
we've said all along that prorogation
actually wasted six valuable weeks when
committees could have been considering
discussing
the government contends no one will be
left behind
individuals will have to first on the
first period
apply in arrears but then receive the
funds automatically and then ongoing
from there
it's the same process so they're really
in terms of the timing of the payments
when it all comes out it'll come out the
same amount for the same period of time
the application process for the
replacement to the serb the canada
recovery benefit which is for
self-employed workers and those not
eligible for
ei starts on october 12th and it too
will be paid in arrears
two weeks at a time donna mike look at
her thanks a little girl gets a chance
at a new life in canada
coming up the orphan on her way from a
camp in syria and how
canadian special forces helped
the pandemic has pushed lots of news out
of the headlines including the fate of
thousands of people suspected of
connections to the so-called islamic
state
they're confined to an overcrowded camp
in northeastern syria both former isis
fighters and their families
including at least 46 canadians one of
them is a five-year-old named amira
her parents were killed in an airstrike
and her uncle back in canada has been
desperate to bring her here
to give her a chance at a new life now
as mike derlay reports
it's finally happening the owl hold
detention camp in northern syria
has been described as horrific water and
food are scarce
medicine as well in the course of five
days
in in august there were eight children
under five who
who died from you know various issues
related to
malnutrition and health related
conditions this is where a five-year-old
girl named amira has lived since last
year
after her parents and siblings were
killed in the last battle to destroy
isis
amira has never set foot in canada but
one of her parents
a suspected isis sympathizer was
canadian
and now global news has learned canadian
special operations forces
working on behalf of global affairs
canada got her out of syria
when she arrives in canada she'll live
with her uncle and his family
and become the first canadian
repatriated from the syrian camps for
isis detainees
for a five-year-old to try and put all
of this together it must be
earth-shattering of course she's going
to be welcomed
when she arrives in into the arms of her
her grandparents and her uncle and
start a new life human rights watch says
there are still 46 canadians being held
in the camp
eight men 13 women and 25 children
most of the children are under the age
of six none has been brought before a
judge or charged with a crime
over 20 other countries have managed to
repatriate their citizens from the camp
yet canada has said it was too dangerous
for consular officials
to travel in northern syria it's the
question of political will
and the lack of political will to
repatriate this specific group of
canadians who are detained in northeast
syria
when asked if amira's return would open
the door to others
canadian officials maintained this was
an exceptional case
sometimes you gotta give way to the the
politics and do the right
thing and i think this is a first step
in doing the right
thing um i'm really optimistic that this
might lead to further action on behalf
of the government
mike derlay global news toronto
ahead what medications is president
trump taking we answer more of your
covid19
questions
anyone who tells you they know
everything about covid19 is
lying there is much scientists and
doctors still don't understand but they
are learning new things every day
our jeff semple has been talking to
experts and is here to answer some of
your covid19
questions jeff well donna
donald trump's covid19 cocktail has some
canadians wondering whether that
presidential treatment plan might be
available here
christelle wrote in to ask is rem
desevere
currently available to covet 19 patients
in canada
the answer is yes but not for everyone
it's available mainly through the
context of a trial
or occasionally for a compassionate use
as well rem deserver is the first drug
in canada approved to treat covid19
the intravenous medication is expensive
and in short supply
reserved for hospitalized patients that
drug doesn't save lives but it can
shorten the duration
of hospital stay and make people get
better more quickly
the president also received
dexamethasone a potentially risky
steroid
used in canada to treat severe cases of
covid19
he's the president of the united states
so they're going to throw the kitchen
sink at him
if they can justify it october marks the
start of flu season
in our northern hemisphere and mary
wrote in to ask
what are the main differences between
covid19 symptoms
and a regular cold or seasonal flu
unfortunately from a doctor's standpoint
it's almost impossible to separate the
two the
symptom list overlaps quite a bit the
most common symptoms of covid19
a fever dry cough and fatigue are
similar to the flu
but there are some subtle differences
with the flu you're more likely to have
a headache or muscle pain
while covid19 can affect your sense of
smell or taste
a runny nose meanwhile is most likely a
common cold
and speaking of noses have you ever
wondered whether it might be okay
to slip your mask just south of the
schnauze i see
a lot of people who actually wear a mask
only on their mouth and not their nose
and i always wonder if that is actually
the best way
the so-called half-masters have become a
source of controversy
and for good reason a recent study found
the highest concentration of covid19
infection
is in the nasal passages which is why
wearing a mask below the nose
is a no-no jeff semple global news
toronto next
canada's connection to a nobel prize
decades in the making
a university of alberta virologist is
getting the ultimate recognition for a
medical discovery made over 30 years ago
dr michael houghton has won the nobel
prize in medicine along with two other
researchers
they discovered the hepatitis c virus
and their work went on to save millions
of lives
heather yurick's west on the latest
nobel laureate with a canadian
connection
thirty years ago stephen sheridan was
sure hepatitis c
would kill him the virus made him so ill
he eventually
required a liver transplant i suffered
with it for
almost 14 years before i got my
transplant
and then to be cured
that was beyond my wildest dreams
today sheridan and millions of others
around the world like him
are living healthy lives free of the
blood disease
thanks to the work this university of
alberta researcher began
in 1982 an important
lesson that i've learned is if you want
to solve major problems you've really
got to be persistent
it took dr michael houghton and his
colleagues nearly a decade to fix a
problem
that first came to light in the early
80s when patients who had received
tainted blood transfusions began to fall
ill with a form of hepatitis
unlike anything doctors had ever seen
everyone in canada should be so grateful
to michael because he is the person who
discovered the virus that caused the
tainted blood
scandal that hit canada very hard not
only did houghton's work lead to tests
that could ensure the safety of canada's
blood supply
it also eventually led to the
development of a drug
a cure for what had previously been a
deadly disease
before people were getting infected
there were no there was no treatment
and they were developing a variety of
liver disease
and then some of those required liver
transplantation
about five percent would develop liver
cancer
of course the work for houghton and his
team is not done
he's now working on a vaccine for
hepatitis c while turning his attention
to the kovid 19 fight as well hepsi
kills around 400 000 people every year
so far this year kovitz killed around a
million people
and so these virus viruses are really a
permanent threat
and we need diagnostics we need
antivirals and we need vaccines
and though it may be some time before
this novel coronavirus is finally tamed
steven sheridan is living proof of what
can
be done heather urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this monday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is these seaplanes
docked in vancouver's coal
harbor we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye
[Music]
you